LIFE.
♪ ♪
>> Jesse: HELLO EVERYBODY, I
AM JESSE WATTERS, ALONG WITH
DONNA, DANA, GREG.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
THE BATTLE OVER WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS NOW CALLING THE
CRAZY MUELLER REPORT IS FAR FROM
OVER.
HE'S ALSO TWEETING THAT BECAUSE
HE NEVER AGREED TO TESTIFY IT
WAS NOT NECESSARY FOR ME TO
RESPOND TO STATEMENTS MADE IN
THE REPORTS.
SOME OF WHICH ARE TOTAL BS AND
ONLY GIVEN TO MAKE THE OTHER
PERSON LOOK GOOD OR ME TO LOOK
BAD.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, DEMOCRATS ARE
IN TOTAL DENIAL.
HOUSE JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN JERRY
NADLER HAS SUBPOENAED THE
UNREDACTED REPORT AND HE AND
OTHER LEFT-WING DEMOCRATS ARE
ALSO REFUSING TO ACCEPT REALITY.
>> THE SPECIAL COUNSEL WOULD
HAVE SAID SO, HE DID NOT, HE
LEFT THAT ISSUE TO THE CONGRESS
OF THE UNITED STATES.
>> THE MUELLER REPORT OUTLINES
DISTURBING EVIDENCE THAT THE
PRESIDENT ENGAGED IN DISTURBING
MISCONDUCT.
>> HE SHOULD PROBABLY NOT BE THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
BUT FOR THE RUSSIAN INTERVENTIO
INTERVENTION.
>> Jesse: THAN THERE IS THE
LIBERAL MEDIA MELTING DOWN,
TRYING TO CLAIM COLLUSION EXIST
EXISTS.
>> THEY WANTED TO CONSPIRE, THEY
JUST NEVER FOUND THE RIGHT
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO.
>> I LOOK AT THIS EVIDENCE AND
IT SURE LOOKS LIKE OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE TO ME.
>> IF THERE WASN'T ACTIVE
COLLUSION PROVEN I THINK WHAT WE
HAVE HERE IS CASE OF PASSIVE
COLLUSION.
>> THE CHAPTER ON COLLUSION
SHOWS SIGNIFICANT CONTACT
BETWEEN PEOPLE ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND THE RUSSIANS.
>> I'M NOT GOING TO LET PEOPLE
SAY CNN OR THE MEDIA HAVE BEEN
CREATING A FALSE NARRATIVE.
>> THIS REPORT IS PLENTY OF
PROOF THAT THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
BEEN ASKED REPEATEDLY WERE
LEGIT.
>> Jesse: IT IS FUNNY TO HEAR
THE MEDIA CLAIM THEY ARE
VINDICATED.
>> Greg: I DON'T BLAME THEM,
IT IS EMBARRASSING FOR THEM WHAT
THEY'VE BEEN THROUGH, THEY HAVE
TO GO OUT THERE AND SAVE FACE TO
THE AUDIENCE THEY LIED TO FOR SO
LONG.
EVERY PERSON THAT USED THE WORD
BOMBSHELL, THEY NEED TO GO TO A
GIANT CHALKBOARD AND WRITE
"BOMBSHELL" 10,000 TIMES.
HERE'S A SUMMARY, THIS REPORT
WAS ABOUT ONE QUESTION, DID
TRUMP COLLUDE WITH THE RUSSIANS?
YOU HAVE AN INVESTIGATION TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION, THERE
WASN'T ANY EVIDENCE.
BUT THEY DECIDED TO DO IT ANYWAY
AND WHAT THE INVESTIGATION DID
WAS CREATE WHAT'S CALLED PROOF
OUT OF A SERIES OF UNCONNECTED
INSTANCES AND EVENTS THAT EACH
BY THEMSELVES MEANS NOTHING.
NOW YOU HAVE -- LET ME FINISH.
PART TWO WAS NOTHING BUT THIS
COLLECTION OF STUFF YOU ALREADY
KNEW ABOUT TRUMP.
THAT HE'S MAD, HAS MEETINGS,
THAT HE WANTS TO FIRE PEOPLE.
THAT INVESTIGATION CREATES THE
BELIEF THAT THAT SOMEHOW IS
ILLEGAL, IT'S A COMPLETE SHAM.
THEY HAD TO DO THE SECOND PART
ANYWAY, MAKES NO SENSE TO ME.
>> Donna: I READ A LOT OF THE
SUMMARIES BUT I AM TAKING THIS
HOME TO LOUISIANA.
I THINK IT'S WORTH READING
BEFORE WE START RESPONDING TO OR
MAKING ALLEGATIONS ABOUT WHAT'S
IN IT.
IT IS THOROUGH, IT IS DEEPLY
SOURCED AND WHAT I LIKE ABOUT
THE WAY THE SPECIAL COUNSEL
HANDLES IT IS HE ADDRESSED ALL
OF THESE IMPORTANT, PERTINENT
QUESTION ABOUT RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE AND MEDDLING AND
WHILE THERE WAS NO SO-CALLED
"COLLUSION" --
>> Jesse: OR LITERAL
COLLUSION.
>> Donna: THERE WAS A LOT OF
PENETRATION.
IF >> Jesse: WERE YOU READING
THE SAME REPORT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Donna: I WAS TOO YOUNG TO
HAVE READ THAT.
>> Greg: I GOT THE AUDIOBOOK.
>> Donna: THIS WAS A LOT OF
RUSSIAN WHOEVER THAT TRIED TO
MAKE CONTACT WITH THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN AND GUESS WHAT?
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WANTED THE
INFORMATION BUT THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION.
IF YOU WANT TO PROTECT OUR
DEMOCRACY, IF THE PRESIDENT
WANTS TO CLEAR THE AIR, LET
CONGRESS COMPLETE ITS JOB, IT
WILL NOT MESS WITH YOUR BASEBALL
SEASON, I SWEAR.
>> Jesse: MY ONLY POINT IS, I
AGREE, READ IT, THE MEDIA SHOULD
NOT BE TRYING TO CRIMINALIZE
CASUAL BEHAVIOR AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE DOING WITH PART TWO.
>> Jesse: IF YOU KNOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WAS NOT A TRAITOR AND WASN'T AN
ASSET OF PUTIN, YOU SHOULD BE
HAPPY ABOUT THAT BUT THEY ARE
CHERRY PICKING IT AND SAID THIS
WAS HAPPENING, THIS WAS
HAPPENING SO THEY HAVEN'T REALLY
GRASPED THAT.
IT SEEMS LIKE EVERYBODY IS JUST
KIND OF SEEING IT FOR WHAT THEY
SAW BEFORE IT WAS RELEASED.
>> Dana: JUNE 16TH 2015 WHEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAME DOWN THE
ESCALATOR AND ANNOUNCED HE WAS
GOING TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT,
EVERY STORY SINCE THEN HAS BEEN
ABOUT HIM.
EVER SINCE THIS REPORT CAME OUT
IT'S STILL ALL ABOUT HIM.
THE MAIN HEADLINES TO ME WERE
BURIED IN THERE, THE RUSSIAN
INTERFERENCE WAS DEEPER AND
BROADER THAN WE THOUGHT, THERE
WAS AN ABILITY FOR HACKERS TO
GET INTO A VOTING COMPUTER, THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO INFLUENCE THE
OUTCOME BUT THEY WERE ABLE TO DO
IT AND I WONDER ABOUT THIS.
IN ADDITION TO THE ORIGINS OF
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, WHY ISN'T ANYBODY
ASKING OBAMA, HOW DID YOU LET
THIS GET THIS FAR?
YOU WERE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROTECTING THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY OF THE UNITED STATES.
I THINK THAT MIGHT BE A
QUESTION, THIS IS OUR
CATASTROPHIC FAILURE.
ASIDE FROM THE FACT THAT YOU
DIDN'T WANT TO LOOK LIKE YOU ARE
PUTTING YOUR THUMB ON THE SCALE
FOR THE CAMPAIGN, WHY DID YOU
FAIL?
>> Donna: I CAN TELL YOU THE
LITTLE BIT I KNOW IN TERMS OF
THE DNC, WE WERE INFORMED ON
WHAT WAS HAPPENING BUT IT WAS
TOO LATE BECAUSE THE RUSSIANS
HAD ALREADY SPENT ALMOST A YEAR
INSIDE OF OUR SYSTEMS.
AND BY THE TIME WE GOT TO IT WE
WERE WIPED OUT.
>> Dana: A YEAR BEFORE THAT,
WHAT HAPPENED THEN?
>> Donna: I WASN'T A CHAIR.
I CAN'T SPEAK --
>> Jesse: YOU GUYS DID NOT
HAND OVER THE SERVER.
>> Donna: WE HANDED OVER A
REPLICA.
WE HAD TO FIGURE OUT -- THAT'S
ANOTHER THING.
THIS REPORT GOES INTO DEEP
ANALYSIS OF WHAT HAPPENED, THAT
THEY DID GET THE INFORMATION
THEY NEEDED TO ESTABLISH THAT IT
WAS THE RUSSIANS, THAT IT WAS
THE GR YOU AND THE REPLICA WAS
NECESSARY.
HAD RETURNED OVER OUR BRAINS --
SPEECH TO THE DNC WAS NOT IN
CHARGE OF PROTECTING FLORIDA'S
ELECTION SYSTEM.
MY QUESTION WOULD BE, WHAT
HAPPENED THERE?
>> THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
SUMMARIZED ON AN INDEX CARD, NOT
A 400 PAGE REPORT.
THERE IS NO COLLUSION, SORRY I
WASTED ALL OF YOUR TIME, THAT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE ENTIRE
REPORT BUT WE HAD A $30 MILLION
OPINION PIECE, THE RUSSIANS
DON'T LIKE US, NO SURPRISE, THEY
NEVER LIKED US BUT LEAVES OUT
CONVENIENTLY THE ONE DOCUMENTED
INSTANCE OF KNOWN COLLUSION WE
HAVE.
A FOREIGN SPY ON THE RECORD BY
HILLARY CLINTON'S TEAM WHO SAYS
HE'S GOT INFORMATION FROM
RUSSIANS.
HOW IS THAT NOT IN A REPORT ON
RUSSIAN COLLUSION?
THIS IS NOT A RIDICULOUS
QUESTION IF YOU ARE A RATIONAL
PERSON.
>> Donna: CONGRESS HAS THE
ABILITY --
>> WHY IS IT NOT IN THE REPORT?
THAT'S NOT IN THERE.
>> Donna: YOU KNOW WHAT?
AT THE TIME NOBODY BELIEVED IT
WAS THE RUSSIANS, THAT'S WHY THE
FIRST 56 PAGES ARE ABOUT THEM
ESTABLISHING IT WAS THE RUSSIAN
RUSSIANS.
>> Dan: I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT THESE ARE
OUR FOES, I DON'T THINK THEY
WERE TARGETING ONE SPECIFIC
PARTY.
IF WE ARE INTERESTED IN THE
RUSSIANS TRYING TO HURT OUR
DEMOCRACY WHY DOES THE ANGLE OF
DISINFORMATION FROM THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN NOT
INTEREST ANY ENTREPRENEURIAL
JOURNALIST?
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS FINALLY
COMING AROUND TO THAT STORY.
>> Jesse:
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"?
>> Dan: I'M HEARING SOME
RUMORS.
EVEN THE TIMES IS STARTING TO
SAY, HEY, MAYBE WE MISSED THIS
ANGLE.
>> Jesse: "THE DAILY CALLER"
IS NOW REPORTING ON
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" ."
>> Donna: WHY DID
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THEN CANDIDATE
TRUMP, SAY "COME ON, I WANT MORE
WIKILEAKS."
>> Jesse: THAT'S WHAT TRUMP
DOES.
WHEN I SET ABOUT THE PART TWO,
WE KNOW -- WE GOT A $30 MILLION
BOOK REPORT ON DONALD TRUMP'S
BEHAVIOR.
BY THE THING IS, WHAT THE MEDIA
IS GOING TO DO IS TAKE ABSENCE
OF EVIDENCE AND SAY THAT DOESN'T
MEAN INNOCENCE.
IT IS GOING TO BE HE'S GUILTY.
>> Dan: HILLARY CLINTON IS
PAID BEHIND THE SCENES TO GET
NEGATIVE INFORMATION, TRUMP IS
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA, WHAT IS
WORSE?
I DON'T GET THE DOUBLE STANDARD.